uh yes yes we do and um
you know what coffin breaker might not
actually be the official name also i
might we might have to look it up later
on but yeah whatever whatever worked for
both of us right
back one plus two maru
i did uh dm mario earlier and he i asked
him what character he used to use lydia
and you know if he chooses to stick with
the character for an entire tournament
he will keep using lydia he's been
practicing lydia also and
what do you think of lydia rip
olivia is a very good move you know
she's got that move forward one pursue
the political story move uh that is just
such a good uh long-range punisher right
so it just moves that it's only like -10
i believe for the third and fourth it so
she kind of just throw it out there uh
and it's like oh did it work did it not
work i'm not really sure let's find out
and i feel like it's a very very
spammable move and usually for me when i
see spammable moves in tekken those are
moves that i feel need to be nerfed uh
you know i feel like third and fourth it
they probably should make them more
punishable and blocked uh but we don't
get lydia and we don't get leroy we get
brian fury from coffee prince and we get
negan coming out of maru
maru you liar anyway negan also really
good i i've been using negan a lot uh
online pretty fun character uh also you
know copy prince does have a pocket
brian fury but he doesn't feel like
using steve fox he goes for the brian
fear let's see how things are going to
go here round one
interesting
do you think he expected the negan pick
though
i don't think so mario doesn't really
pull out the negan that much
yeah this is an interesting choice
okay hey
mario trying to get out of the wall
coffee friends trying to keep him there
both players nearly outside nearly
getting rage
coffee friends looking for more mid
pokes not going for a lot of hatching
kicks but sidestep two
maru gonna close this one out coffee
prince
round two
that was beautiful i love that the way
negan says boom during it too
hey
he's a big fan of uh wow
he's a big he's a big fan he's a rip fan
he is
he probably liked law
do you think so
yeah i think he means paul
oh no you know what for that i i'll
think so too but here we go maru breaks
that uh breakable wall but coffee prince
gets out of there safely mario does have
racial counter hit one two one down
forward to check
coffee prince dude
i'm not gonna lie that tom jennifer
looked pretty good even though it wasn't
you know in a state where you can see if
standing whether it's not but the time
look pretty clean
all right the first few hatchimals we've
seen in this uh
in this set let's see can coffee fans
continue this trade
not in favor of maru the oak is still
there for coffee friends outside of rage
also coffee prince
man this is back and forth right now
maro finally creating a little bit of
face like nope too much space
right back in tomorrow with the lead to
route to one here
plus four gonna carry on to the wall
also but just a bit short he will get
them there oh
my goodness
let's go copy friends showing us how
it's done
i feel like mario's probably hitting
buttons there but doesn't matter
compliments quick answer back final
round game one
conference looking warmed up with the
brian fury
[Music]
right now struggling to find a single
opening for copy friends and he's been
punishing he's been poking about so well
sidestepping everything for copyrights
working out
oh my goodness not that though
here we go maru
bringing it back has the life lead now
back waffles to abuse the plus braves
but he contests he can test the floss
frames from negan and maru takes game
one big mistake from coffee prince
huge and like in that situation why
would you think he wouldn't press a
button maybe i'm not sure what he was
thinking that would be coming instead
for the pressure uh but unfortunate
situation for coffee prince you know
earlier i was saying i wanted to see him
run through the bracket with leroy see
if we can get a leroy to win the
tournament uh bring out the brian fury
here and brian obviously a very strong
character right now as well we saw he
has taunts ready to go as well uh
unfortunately you know just swinging at
the wrong time there really cost him uh
and maru with the negan pick probably
caught him a little bit off guard
and a coffee prince is kind of known for
pressing on certain situations where
you're not supposed to press mainly
because it catches the throws off guard
but
this obviously it wasn't uh wasn't one
of those cases it did not work out well
for him so he might go for a switch here
probably most likely the leroy i'm i'm
really hoping for the steve though
interesting okay uh you know you said
you've been using a lot of negan lately
is steve one of those characters that's
kind of a hard match for negan i've
heard that characters who have like a
magic four are difficult for negan to
contest uh but maybe steve you know with
a back one it's a similar situation
personally i think characters who can
sidestep well are really good against
negan because negan is linear as all
hell uh
he he does have a few moves that track
like back to maybe even like sidestep
two but that's pretty much about it his
back one oneplus two his best plus frame
move is linear so you know that's gonna
be that's one of the fifth difficult
parts about negan but coffee prince does
stick with the brian
oh my goodness
what
[Music]
yeah for sure coffee prince again
looking a bit flustered here maru taking
that wave of momentum in round one
oh boy
count up down four three this time
all right conference got married to the
wall here taunt jet upper no-go
okay oh god yeah
yeah he didn't believe enough
yeah that was a really odd exchange
after getting the launch with the jet
upper
but regardless confidence on the board
at the round count tied now beautiful
duck on the high string but man the
cobbles are dropping for coffee prince
right now
oh maru you can see that he's abusing a
lot of these ff one plus twos because
coffee first is getting caught by it
probably prince though counter hit f3
going to see the walls
todd
man the top that's not working right now
the tiniest of pixels
did he try delayed hopkins
i think he did yeah i think he was
trying to get the ticket coming through
maru though again
we cannot count him out topic
one two four punish good perfect
punishment
yeah that ten frame is one of the best
in the game
but man coffee prince like to hit some
buns right now
yeah
he's on fire with these buttons and he's
not stopping again against the likes of
maru he does have him up against
the wall bounce cutting next and here we
go what's the mix up going to be oh try
to go for them no todd get up for
yo he tried to parry and the bat came
out right then too
[Music]
okay no too far barely barely misses the
punch
just walking back
back and now that was tight not the
punish
yo
set point for maru now coffee prince
facing elimination again backswing start
of the round
the carry to the wall now has him the
pressure is on mar with no exceptions
coffee prince half health we're only 10
seconds in 13 frames punished good maru
with the blocks again coffee prince with
the challenge and maru takes it against
coffee prince eliminating it from the
tournament two to zero
out of here coffee prince goes down
without trying the leroy out and yet
again
we don't see a leroy that far in the
bracket man what's going on i thought
this character is supposed to be so good
kid you know i'm just saying uh leroys
aren't winning
results space tearless let's go leroy no
good uh get him out of here uh but we do
see there the negan coming out getting
the results done uh over brian fury very
nicely done very nicely done
yeah it's it's pretty weird to me how
coffee prince didn't choose to go for
the leroy that time because leroy would
i think i think leroy would have been
you know a much better decision there
but considering how long these guys have
been playing with each other they know
each other all too well so a lot of
things have to be you know switched up
there so i think that's an
understandable decision from coffee
prince
yeah and yeah first i just i just wanted
to see leroy you know i just we don't
get to see enough leroy's anymore in
tournament uh the character's still i
think very fun to watch uh unfortunately
you know brian though also a very fun
character to watch you know coffee fits
put on a show with his brian
unfortunately you know a lot of the toss
up did not work out for him there uh and
maru that surprised megan pickens negan
looks good you know i think uh in north
america at least we've been seeing negan
kind of make this uh
like it's like a second wave